that's my review that's good that's hot
put it on the model oh yeah well that's
good that's hot
yeah she's so well-spoken hey what's
going on everybody for first we feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones it's the show with hot questions it
even had her wings and today we're
joined by Kristen Bell this is one of
the most successful actresses in
Hollywood of the career and TV and film
that includes everything from box office
smashes to belove cult classics speaking
of the former frozen to hits theaters
this November and on the topic of the
ladder you can catch new episodes of
Veronica Mars streaming on Hulu now
Kristen Bell welcome to the show thank
you for having me I'm hungry so I'm
happy to be here well you know a few
years ago your husband Dax completed one
of the most impressive runs that we've
ever seen on hot ones how much pride
does he take in that particular
wing-eating exhibition too much too much
he definitely leads certain
conversations with but you know I think
I'm the reigning champion on hot ones
which look we eat a lot of hot sauce at
home we like hot stuff so I think it's
either when you could say we're good at
it we're you know athletes or we've
killed our taste buds
[Music]
okay just eat it
mm-hmm it's all you well that's
beautiful
[Music]
so while we're sitting here eating vegan
wings in Hollywood I think now's as
perfect time as any
to unpackage this great Kristen Bell
quote I crave Midwestern food and
atmosphere there is no [ __ ] oh yeah
well there isn't you you just mentioned
you're from chicago yep yep
I mean I'm caught in the middle because
I'm also very much susceptible to
ordering like anything on a menu that
says like the California Gurls sandwich
the California girl meal I'm like that's
exactly what I want was I like eating
healthy food out here but there's
something about the atmosphere of the
Midwest and we just went to Lake
Michigan spent 4th of July there it just
felt like home and miss it for the
uninitiated can you explain the enduring
allure of sliding into a vinyl booth at
a big boy restaurant in Michigan Wow
there's nothing like it
it's like cheers big voices like cheers
and it sometimes it's out of a time
machine but sliding into that booth
knowing you're about to get an unlimited
salad bar and not really caring how many
days the lettuce has been in there
because you're just there for the blue
cheese everything about it is great
and this is made with tumeric mm-hmm
we're in flaming our taste buds with hot
sauce and then the inflammation is
coming from the turmeric it's a full
circle it really is what a nice sauce
what a thoughtful sauce so I want to
stay on the topic of food because the
good place is low key one of the best
food shows on television constantly
applying the everything is not as it
seems theme to the culinary world can
you give me the BTS behind the clam
chowder fountain mm-hmm it is a writer
named Megan Amram she has one of the
most interesting brains currently on the
planet she had kind of has a tick for
puns and so all of the like lasagna come
out tomorrow which is the name of the
Italian restaurant in the good place the
scottie pippen
yes exactly pesto's yet-to-come exactly
those are all Megan Amram and she has a
thing about she wrote three or four clam
chowder jokes into that episode one I
think was that it's just hot milk with
dead animal croutons there were a bunch
of clam chowder jokes and she pitched
during her episode that we fill the
whole fountain with it and we said it's
a good place why not and then of course
what I like about the show is it seems
to serve as like a blank canvas for the
writers to just express their various
culinary gripes have you ever had a food
pet peeve worked into the show and if
not is the one you'd like to share with
us one of the most brilliant things I've
ever read or been a part of was when you
know the good place is centered around
all these yogurt shops and it's because
Ted care Ted's character says yogurt
frozen yogurt is so uniquely human it's
so human to take something great like
ice cream and ruin it just a little bit
so that you can have a lot more
[Music]
and I do like that it's getting hotter I
gotta say you know what when we went to
Rwanda my husband and I went on a trip
to Africa and saw a bunch of beautiful
countries right before our kids were
born it was our last hurrah being
autonomous adults and we had dinner in
Rwanda and they have a type of hot sauce
they're called acha Bunga do you know it
not familiar can I get you some school
me you have to you buy it I think in
like a pharmacy you have to use gloves
while you handle it and it comes in like
it looks what looks like a medicine
bottle and it is like a neon yellow
liquid and you could make a vat of soup
and put like three drops in it and it is
on fire but I do love that ah Kabongo
sauce so Veronica Mars it's taken such
an interesting journey through the
shifting sands of the entertainment
industry starting out on cable and then
having this crowd-sourced movie and then
being birthed again now in a streaming
service have you ever given any thought
to that journey and then the power of a
ride-or-die fan base and what that power
can mean in 2019 the only reason that we
are doing more Veronica Mars is because
our fans are ride or die and they are so
loud and they also are smart which is
flattering that smart people watch the
show that you're in you're not mindless
entertainment in the background but the
the fans have organized themselves I
mean the first year when we were on UPN
they were sending Mars bars into UPN
saying say Veronica Mars the second year
they were sending dollar bills which was
a part of the show that said Veronica
Mars is smarter than me the third year
they hired a plane to fly above the CW
with a banner that said save Veronica
Mars I mean they are organized although
I will say making the movie because it
was crowdfunded
we took a lot of responsibility trying
to make the movie what the fans wanted
put in all the Easter eggs Rob Thomas
literally wrote a scene where Veronica
who was ostracized in high school he
wrote a scene where she punched out the
most popular girl in high school and
then he reverse engineered the script
because he was like I'm gonna give the
fans exactly what they want that's what
we gave him with the movie because they
crowdfunded it with this new series on
hulu it was a chance to make veronica
more complex not necessarily give the
fans what they want but maybe give him
what Veronica needs do you ever feel
like a push and pull with that like a
tug of war with that because sometimes I
do with hot ones the fan base is so call
but then there's this tightrope walk
where you want to be grateful but not
behold it yeah and I'm dealing with that
right now because there are new there
are things that happen in this series
the new one that some of our diehard
fans were very upset about they were not
happy I almost wish I could talk to each
of them at length and say Robb
represented a really complex female
character she's not just the girl who's
making great decisions in the world is
happening to her you know part of the
show is that she doesn't want to get
married to this guy who seems perfect
for her and I think that's fine I don't
think it has to be everyone's happy
ending but that's a complex thing to
introduce to people who want Veronica's
happiness so much
how many whims do you think you've eaten
in your life well if I'm just doing the
math you know we're like 170 episodes
into this so if you do that times 10
that already puts me at just 1700 wings
that I've eaten on YouTube for people
yeah you know not to say anything you
know a Super Bowl party no tailgate like
I'm just saying just straight on the
clock so we all got wings yeah I love
them if I'm not you know I'd never order
them off a menu if I'm being real with
you Chris yeah you know like at this
point it would feel it would feel like
work mm-hmm on some level you know then
go yeah I'd never go to a restaurant do
a monologue for anyone right I hear you
it's like I'm not working off the clock
over here you know so this is the first
time in the history of this show that
we've never had the fully formed couple
on hot ones so here we want to
fact-check Dax's interview with you
Chris I would love nothing more than to
fact-check my husband okay he spoke at
length about his man crushes which
included jay-z
has he ever embarrassed you at a
function or party fanboy not a little
too hard yes we went to the Met Gala a
couple years ago and we were sitting
right next to jay-z and Beyonce
and when we found this out we were
forget it we were so excited and I was
like oh this gonna be great finally well
looked after tonight when our phones
we'll be best friends and then we
maneuvered the table so that Dax could
sit right next to jay-z and Dax talked
his ear off and I don't think Jay was
that interested but I was proud of him
that he went for broke take some courage
talk to the person you love I think at
one point he also hit him with a lyric
where I was like I think it was like
real recognize real and I was like text
acts don't don't where we at with the
Costco obsession is he still out there
bargain huntin Oh hundred percent a
hundred percent he actually told a story
about Costco last night
but he's not you know someone I was at
the checkout line in Costco and the
woman checking me out goes oh I heard
you died and he goes well really and she
goes yeah I don't her told me you died
and he goes Wow
I mean well I didn't but how did I die
and she said oh I earn ask and then he
walked away feeling really low he's like
do you know how uninteresting you have
to be to not have someone ask how you
died are you here he said last night
he's like you hear Sean Penn died first
follow-up how right she just read the
headline it didn't he's dead okay and
then finally we hit him with a math quiz
at the end and me nearly aced it but got
this one wrong so I'm gonna bounce it
off you to see me break the record
all right I'm ordering three hot sauces
online sriracha for five dollars Tabasco
for $5.99 and de bomb for seven dollars
even if shipping cost 350 and there's no
tax what's my total cost on the order
$17.99 plus 350 is 2149 yes no yes
really you mail this kind of again by
the way I'm impressed that you're doing
the vegan wings like I'm very on that
you know if you can do two days a week
vegan or whatever you know it's not it's
not good for the environment for the
environment you have all these yeah we
have all these right or all these like
farms or whatever you read so much
terrible stuff so I think that you know
not to have like the wing thing all the
time you know it's nice you're nice
thank you guys I appreciate that I
custom every crane segment on our show
called explain that grammar to a deep
dive on I guess Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture and then you just
tell me the bigger story does that sound
good
mm-hmm all right
first things first can you give us the
BTS on the choco challenge yeah so the
choco challenge benefited the prostate
cancer foundation
my husband's of prostate cancer
foundation ambassador they said they
sent us some spicy chocolate we're gonna
eat it it's sort of like the ice bucket
challenge you know inspire other people
to eat it and then make a funny video it
was without question the hottest thing I
have ever tasted in my life and you guys
are hardcore we were so arrogant going
into it we're like this is cute for the
prostate cancer foundation we're gonna
eat this and it's gonna be fun and I
mean I can't even describe what it was
like I will tell you if I had the choice
to do that over again or go through
labor over again I'd choose labor Wow
it was unbelievable sensations inside
your body and you've eaten like a
Carolina Reaper before and stuff right
I've eaten when I had to do the Carolina
Reaper challenge I ate one and I felt
immediately codependent because I didn't
think it was that hot and I like acted
it like oh good was so hot and then I
just kept eating them and I had like
seven of them and it wasn't um it didn't
bother me I really enjoy hot stuff this
was all right so here you are just as
Tom Selleck Halloween this doesn't need
any more context I think you know that
and then here you are as Elsa and you
look kind of bummed out yeah well I was
Halloween 2017 such an emotional
rollercoaster for you well I had done I
had hosted the Jimmy Kimmel show when he
was off and it was Halloween and I
thought it'd be a great costume to dress
as Tom Selleck so I nailed it and then
on actual Halloween my daughter
requested that I go as Elsa with her not
that I come as onna the character that I
played but that I actually dressed like
Elsa with her and you can't look at a
four-year-old and say no I'm not gonna
make your Halloween as fun as I could
make it but deep down but deep down it's
a little offensive just because it's
like does anybody care about onna
come he's just heart and soul that film
ooh that's good you like that one so the
good places received a lot of credit for
neatly packaging the tenets of classic
moral philosophers like Aristotle into
this entertaining TV show is there a
philosophical principle that you've
picked up from the show that you find
particularly relevant to how you live
your life yes have vacillated throughout
my life thinking I was a utilitarian
because I do want greater good they
believe that the you have to do
something for the greater good even if
it's if I got to push you off the cliff
to save everyone in this room
utilitarian would say got to do it
content say do the right thing in the
moment which is even if everyone else
has to die I have to save you I will not
push you off the cliff and I find both
of those really compelling arguments and
moral particularism which is a
modern-day philosophy introduced by
Jonathan Dancy who is Hugh Dancy Father
the actor he describes moral
particularism as the ability to
vacillate between either of those two
theories and I think that's where I land
how would you sort through the ethics of
this show because on the one side we're
like all right entertaining concept but
there's no getting around the fact that
it's sadistic yeah for sure but I would
also say you have to have a hook right
there's nothing funny or interesting
about perfection you want people to
struggle a little bit this is your
conflict on this interview show this is
your complexity you have to throw a
wrench in the gears in order to make it
worth watching let me hit you with an
ethical query because I'm just curious
how you work through it okay okay all
right so imagine you're working at a
restaurant you realize that when no one
was looking
a deadly chili pepper infected five
bowls of chili
yeah one gluttonous patron has ordered
five orders of chili and then five other
not so hungry patrons have ordered one
bowl each the killer chili is headed
towards the five not so hungry customers
but you can step in
divert all the bowls to the one glutton
do you let the five bowls of death chili
go out to the not so hungry patrons or
do you intervene saving the five lives
but killing the glutton so you can
either save the five not so hungry or
killed the one glutton you're hitting me
with a the trolley problem here it is
the trolley problem I gotta go I'm gonna
go I divert the chili yeah he's he's out
I don't have the opportunity to save
everyone know you have to go one of the
other it's that trolley I'm gonna be
utilitarian
this says fearless flavor I agree that's
good
that's hot too
[Music]
that's my review that's good that's hot
put it on the model oh yeah well that's
good that's hot oh she's so well-spoken
how does the pressure of wrapping a film
and then waiting for the box office
numbers to come in how does that compare
to hopping into the late-night seat and
guest hosting on Jimmy Kimmel Live ooh
I actually don't ever pay attention to
box office numbers I never have for the
safety of my brain and my ego mm-hmm I
want people to go see it like I want
people to love Veronica Mars of a good
place I want there to be an audience but
I don't necessarily care about the
competition of it all and I think it's
unhealthy if I'm preoccupied with that
versus preoccupied with making the best
show possible
and exposing it to a large amount of
people are you preoccupied with the
critical reception of it that a little
bit more yeah because that can actually
make or break a movie but this is
something I talked to myself in my head
all the time about cuz I'm like eat if
you were happy when you watched it and
you felt confident that is the only
thing that should matter it is the only
thing that should matter
it isn't always because I'm just a human
being but and jumping into the
late-night seat was just fun to be
honest because I can read a teleprompter
like a [ __ ] okay because the
words are right there
[Music]
that one's [ __ ] hot yeah hmm now
we're getting into real territory here
mm-hmm
yeah so when you went on Dax's armchair
expert podcast he made the point that
you're impossible to watch TV shows or
movies with me too yeah me too
can I take my shirt off because you'll
have to constantly mimic the lines where
does that impulse come from don't know
it's a tick it's like I can't explain it
when I hear something that sounds funny
in my ear which unfortunately is usually
usually other people's accents I have to
say I have to say it so it makes it
miserable to watch like Game of Thrones
or peaky blinders next to me because I'm
just like talking it in my hand doing a
voice in Assassin's Creed did you get a
newfound respect for the narrative
storytelling in video games these days
[Music]
yes but I mostly just had fun with that
because I don't know that at the time
when I did it because that was like 15
years ago I wasn't necessarily tracking
the narrative as much as I should have
been I was just like oh [ __ ] cool I'm
in the Assassin's Creed video game the
other thing that stuck is almost every
Disney movie I've ever seen I could do
from start to finish with all the voices
and I do the voices when I read um them
to my kids like the books and they hate
it
they're like stop doing scuttles voice
just do a regular voice I'm like but
he's scuttle the seagull and they don't
like it
[Music]
listen you ready to move on [ __ ] I think
so I'm I love swear yeah okay so this
one's the chocolate plague from pucker
bud pepper company pucker but hmm
hmm this has more of a flavor than the
last one for sure because this was more
of a burn mm-hmm and this has more of a
flavor and I like that okay I dig it
it absolutely has Zero nutritional value
you guys literally vitamin A zero C zero
calcium zero iron zero total
carbohydrate 0.3 grams so we wouldn't be
doing this episode justice if we didn't
dive into some of the off Pease
obsessions of Kristen Bell and I know
that your idea of a Golden Globes
after-party it's plain that settlers of
catan at home in your pajamas and that
can be kind of a rift causing game have
you ever been forced to tears or into a
violent rage playing that board game
100% 100 P yes we play together we
almost always fight and we have had to
create a code word to make sure that we
don't go to bed angry
and it's anaconda and when we see a
fight brewing we have to all go anaconda
it's only a game so that we actually
have to put a little bit of our physical
body into it to get us out of our
fighting heads you're a self-described
skeeball freak do you have any pro tips
not a freak I'm just an excellent
athlete always go for the hundreds don't
waste your time with the 40's and
whatever you use this child's play
you've got to go for the hundreds of the
50s it's the only way to play skee-ball
I know that you're a game of Thrones
superfan you have a hot take on the last
season oh man
look I don't want to sling any [ __ ]
you're a beast you're doing that you're
a beast are you trying to bait me to do
it you love this stuff
that's a funny lead that's a funny lead
well it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on that one on the last one
always did my husband do it you know
what your husband did actually he not
only did that he called in for another
way to do it again
a piece of [ __ ] um Game of Thrones it
will say I thought that John and
Khaleesi thing could have been a lot
Messier this was an opinion given to me
by Josh Lawson who I was on House of
Lies with him he was explaining this to
me because I was like desperate to give
that writers room some respect I was
like come on they can't please everyone
right and you're close to it yes I'm
like it was great they tried it was
wonderful you know this was their story
it's not my job to judge and then Josh
Lawson was like yeah but didn't you want
to see more didn't want to see her
stumble back didn't you want to see him
fight didn't you want to see her scream
at him didn't you want to see him don't
just go for her and I was like yeah I
did I wanted it to be messy like Ned
Stark
it's a thick boy whoa okay all right we
go here we go cheers Cheers
oh yeah oh yeah
all right Kristen Bell here we are at
the summit of spice mountain and yeah
covered a lot of terrain today but one
glaring blind spot is your love of
sloths and humbly I would say that you
have a lot to do with this sloths
revolution you know I think at one point
the sloth it was a sleepy afterthought
but now you see the sloths on like urban
outfitter socks and papyrus greeting
cards so now that we've eaten ten
scorching hot chicken wings I have to
ask and as much detail as possible
why do slots have such a special place
in your heart they speak to me because
they really are just a junk drawer of an
animal they are they're like a pig meets
a monkey but with the reflexes of your
grandmother and how are any of those
things bad like those things are greater
than the sum of their parts right right
I also think I'm a pretty fast-paced
person I talk fast I do things fast and
they just remind me to slow down that's
why I love them well there you have it
Kristen Bell's love of sloths and look
at you take in you don't have to do it
no you don't I'm worried that way okay
taking the vegan wings down to the stick
and now before I choke on it there's
nothing left to do but raw off the red
carpet for you Kristen Bell this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on into your
life wait what if you have a new project
oh oh um my first project is my nose
stripping right now because of the hot
sauce the good place will be starting
September 26 I believe on NBC it's our
last season I'm really proud of it the
finale will be well worth the wait
Veronica Mars is streaming on Hulu now
it's a new season it is an older more
complex Veronica and frozen will be
out November 20 something this year
frozen - good job you killed that I knew
you would we have hot sauces at home
that are just called like [ __ ] you like
that's I think it's funny about that
sauce it's like the blood of Satan yes
wait what do we do we just drink and we
go mm-hmm hey what's going on hot ones
fans this is Sean Evans checking in to
say thank you so much for watching
today's episode and if you were ever on
the fence about the subscription box
this month is the month you will get the
hot ones trio pack including the
sold-out Carolina Reaper Edition last
app that's right the only way to get the
Carolina Reaper edition last tab is in
the subscription box and the only way to
get the subscription box is through heat
mist heat mist calm heat nice calm to
order be careful out there dab heads and
Godspeed
[Music]